talking about
the relationship between different
levels of description and so forth but
there are certain features of the actual
evolution of the universe and life on
earth that seem to be important that I
want to know what people feel about
their universality and how important
they were or how robust they were in
some sense so one at the very very
abstract level is just the development
of complexity from the early universe
which is very simple it became more
complex our best theory now says in the
future will eventually go away that the
complexity is a temporary phenomenon and
maybe even the better one to talk about
is natural selection and that might go
back to the teleology questions when we
talk about the origin of life you know
at what point even if we don't have the
origin of life if we have if we can talk
about what might have happened at what
point would we say okay now natural
selection is operating and at the
development of society or or memes or
any of anything else is there some
demarcation that you know some phase
transition which we say now it is a
useful thing to talk about pressures of
selection acting on these different
pieces of information traveling through
time is that something that is under
this is not something understood by me
so there's something is understood by
other people he's sort of physics is
committed to plank
the universe the only way they could do
so is by a process of blind variation
and environmental filtration and that
assurance is vouchsafe to us by the
second law of thermodynamics okay I
agree on that and of course there are if
there is complexity and diversity that
shows that a person it's the result of
Darwinian process and that's guaranteed
by that community there's any that again
that if there is diversity and
complexity that reflects adaptation then
that could only have emerged from zero
an application via the second law
processes as dictated by degrees what
does it mean for an 8-bit of complexity
to be something show adaptation an
update yeah but to the question no
adaptation is going to be cashed in in
terms of some combination of stability
and and replication slowing the talk
that for a moment say you look and click
every now and then a mutation happens
physics explains why whatever now most
of those are not adaptive once in a blue
moon one of them is about by the second
law and which ones are adaptive is a
function of depends on a the second law
and on the myriad details of the
particular environment which it happens
manner so that's the role at history
plays and so evolution is an amplifier
of historical accident and when that
starts amplifying it amplifies blindly
in a sense Android you know an apple ice
wastefully and then
and minimal energetics
but something that follows from that I
think is that it's a mistake to ask at
what point where do we draw the line and
say above this is adaptation below this
isn't because every thing which is
manifestly of adaptations is actually
preceded by an indefinitely long
sequence of things which are willing to
accept that it is subject to the
understanding that at the start of the
process there's zero adaptation sure
okay and then the merest slightest first
unit of adaptation is the product of the
operation of the sector and every
subsequent addition is also the
operation of the second and that's all I
was trying to say by saying when
adaptation appears it's driven by the
same well no see that's what I'm not
gonna go because all you're saying there
and I would agree is that all of that
other patient is a process it better be
compatible its facilitated it made
possible by among other things the
second law fine but there is nothing
about the second law that I can see that
says that there will be at the top
celebrity exactly right right right
there which music whatever that the
universe can exist for too short a time
or existed for a very long time without
the first slightest bit of adaptation
correct because the second law is
probabilistic correct so doesn't that
imply that therefore natural selection
and operations are compatible with but
not determined by the second law well
you know actually that's why can I come
in on an Alexa side this time I think
that you know there is this debate we
always thought with the creationists
when they say well life wouldn't have
just happened
the second law says everything lines
down and so forth I think that's a
misunderstanding entropy in the second
ball and Alan concerning we would be
there but I would even go further to say
that forgetting about life and
adaptation and just sticking to a
somewhat easier to define a notion of
complexity I think one can make the
argument that the evolution of
complexity from simplicity requires the
second law requires the entropy you know
to be way far from an equilibrium and
entropy is increasing and I almost want
to say except then Alex would start
disagrees with me that the reason why
complexity appears is because the
universe wants to generate I don't
understand why you're saying that you're
putting in that way or alex is putting
in that way I mean nobody's denying here
that evolution requires the second law
we're simply saying that that's not the
only thing that requires and therefore
the second law doesn't determine it no
no there is not they should let sprout
in between those two statements you made
which is that I would say that there is
a sense in which evolution or complexity
or whatever is sort of a spin-off of the
second law okay you know it's not just
that it requires it and also other
things it's that it's a very natural
consequence under very wide ranges of
conditions but I think well I think we
don't know what Massimo is concerned is
that nobody make the mistake that was
that actually that Richard pointed out
before and that is of thinking that
there's something like momentum in
evolution
so that right you think well the second
law is gonna guarantee no it's gonna
guarantee nothing because maybe maybe
every evolutionary track we look at dies
out almost immediately it happens
eventually that some things
but don't think that but when you say it
happened and there are wide range of
conditions we don't know that no we
don't have any more water that's fine
let me give a tiny little bit of data
which is very very very tiny but it's
the data that I have so and again since
I'm a physicist don't think about
complexity more than evolution in
particular but I think the complexity
would come first and then you can start
talking about evolution so the level of
my ability to understand things is
mixing milk into coffee so if you
imagine you know you have a little bit
of milk on top of your cup of coffee
that's a very simple system notes on top
coffees on the bottom and on defining
simplicity vs. complexity as sort of the
comb all grow up complexity that is to
say how much data would I need to give
you to fully tell you what you were
seeing when you look at the things so if
all the milks on the top and all the
coffee's on the bottom that's it I just
described the whole system it's simple
it's also low entropy right is a maximal
separation between the milk in the
coffee they mix them all together then
it's again simple they're all mixed
together that's all you all I need to
tell you in the coarse grained
description the information is conserved
actually in the fine-grained description
but then the corresponding difference
very simple but it's high entropy it's
as mixed as you could get so the
interesting question relevant to this
discussion is what is the trajectory
from the simple low entropy
configuration to the simple high entropy
configuration and it allows for the
appearance of complexity you can have
swirls of the coffee in the cream that
are very interesting and he'll maybe
there's little life forms that form in
them or whatever okay that's the model
the whole universe the universe was
simple and low entropy it will be simple
and high entropy it is now complex and
middle middle entry but and so I think
you can you can do it and I have done it
too you know with collaborators you can
sort of ask well under different models
of how the milk and the coffee mix how
does the complexity evolve and if it's
sort of the the milk is a coffee are non
interacting with each other moving
separately then you get a little tiny
bit of more complexity with that
if there's a tight coupling between the
melt and the coffee so that there's only
injured changes at the interface between
them and you get more complexity along
the way before it goes down so I have no
idea whether this is sort of robust and
fascinating and interesting and
universal and explains the existence of
life but you can imagine sort of this
this kind of analysis moving from the
second law which is the foundation of
all this stuff - what other sets of
constraints do we have to put on to say
not only is Ector be increasing but the
way this increasing is favours the
emergence of complexity and even
adaptation and life so I saw it I don't
agree with my see well in the sense that
yes I don't know the conditions under
which it happens but figuring out the
conditions under which it happens it
seems like a very reasonable research
program so the one thing is missing in
your story is of course something
analogous to memory something analogous
to genetics that is in order for this
process in life to get more complex it
basically has to remember it can't
forget what happened the last generation
it can't throw all the information away
you have to accumulate that you have to
accumulate the for the mutations or
whatever and throw throw the vast
numbers of those away but have something
that allows you to accumulate this maybe
that's the answer to when you can start
talking about that okay and the key is
to accumulate it you have to continually
regenerate constraints which take work
which would generate entropy that's not
a trivial question how do you do that
that's that seems to me a question that
we've ignored we preach we say yeah okay
it reproduces it copies and we got more
of this stuff and it passes on I think
it's a totally non-trivial question to
add to this problem yeah okay for
increased entropy and though from the
total and yeah there's there
self-organization that can show up but
it's a bigger story and as I understand
the origin of life issues which is not
very well again there's a metabolism
first school in the replication first
school of thought and I'm a physicist I
like the metabolism first
but because of energy and entropy are
involved I can certainly imagine there
was this intermediate phase of life
where you probably should call it life
it was metabolizing it had structure and
complexity and it couldn't replicate yet
right and so there was no adaptation
there was no natural selection in any
useful form but it was the last natural
selection there was no response to
selection fine very good there's no
adaptation all right so I think so why
does it stick around
well stability it was just an automatic
stability yeah I mean you know there's a
enough of it and it wouldn't have stuck
around forever unless the annotation
kicked
you